wall
and uh yeah we're waiting anxiously yeah
his first move attention before game
three starts they are both ready i have
to say ding now he looks fresher he
looks uh ready to fight and here we go
yep here we go queen spawn opening he's
surprised by this one it looks like he's
repeating the same thing
okay this knight move slightly different
so slightly different variation but it
is the queen's gambit declined
ding here there's a variety of moves
they call this the main position or at
least alexander gristrok does because
black has six or seven very
sensible moves okay he goes for
uh just a kind of nice solid pawn
position
oh this one is
until this last move it was about to
lead into one of the most complex most
aggressive openings out there in chess
uh this is the semi-slav now if you look
at black structure there's kind of a
triangle formation the black pawns
ivanka what do you think of this choice
by both players actually yeah it's uh
very very solid and i think it's the
right way to go because
the other line which would be wild wild
wild as if black gets greedy and
captures material don't touch that
unless you know what you're doing and we
have
we have an opening on the board when the
queen comes out it's actually called the
cambridge springs oh uh it was played
in america this time this uh opening
yeah i'm not sure exactly when but it's
quite an old opening yeah it is a very
old opening and history definitely
should we show the famous trap in the
cambridge springs oh there's a couple of
traps here um which one do you want to
show ivanka if the white bishop develops
yeah
for example this bishop if it comes out
there are a few problems uh firstly
there's a pin and also the black queen
does stare down along this di along this
line at one of the white bishops so for
example here black can just capture a
pawn distract away the white bishop and
jumping in with the knight now wins a
material this bishop is actually
attacked not just by the knight but also
by the queen from far away and uh now
once the bishop moves or is protected
then the black knight can actually
capture and we would see a situation
like this where black has just won a
pawn for free and you give a check and
it looks like you're about to win the
bishop the white knight can jump back
back and block but this is very good for
black this is one of the main tricks uh
one of the main traps but of course
prague he's too good to fall into a trap
on just move eight instead he trades a
set of pawns and brings his queen one
square forward just defending this
knight and loads of pressure on this
knight now suddenly this is uh a mega
pin uh using the black bishop using the
black queen staring down along this
diagonal it's all about trying to break
through on this piece so white has to
rush and defend it this white rook now
sufficiently defending this knight
and uh okay kicking away this bishop we
will likely see at some point maybe
prague get aggress ding sorry get
aggressive and start throwing pawns down
the board
if ding wants to play safe maybe he'll
just castle away to safety but i don't
think that's on his mind right now you
don't choose this variation just to
timidly castle your king and allow your
opponent's pieces out it's all about
whether white's king can rush away to
safety if he can and prague is doing
great but if dean can whip up an attack
before that then yeah who knows what
will happen it could be a very very
interesting game
cool i don't think we've seen this
opening on the tour actually became
bridge springs at all
no i don't recall seeing it i myself
either um but it's a very very popular
uh opening at all levels and it's it's
kind of become very trendy now because
it was dismissed for a long time has
been oh
you hear this word so many times when it
comes to openings but it's just a
stylistic thing okay it's boring it's
boring getting fun why are you playing
like this is old manchester old people
play like this why are you trying to
kill the risk but uh you know
now with computers exactly comparing new
things with them well yeah and i think
the thing is that the computers kind of
have killed the romance a little bit
from these fantastic openings that you
saw in the olden days you know where
they were sacrificing pieces here and
there and everywhere so everyone's a
little bit kind of nervous about going
into these super sharp openings and
instead they're kind of like well
actually let's take a look at these
more solid openings shall we say they're
equally interesting
if you're inclined that way
and yeah it's just a game
and here we see ding
playing i didn't expect this move but it
is one of the main ideas i thought he
might try and challenge the center but
instead he chooses to
make a square for the light squared
bishop yep so black's light squared
bishop it didn't have anywhere to go
it's always the problem piece in these
queens pawn openings but black's like
square bishop can come out to a couple
of different squares now and
personally i always prefer white
slightly in these positions if you look
in the center of the board white has a
stronghold there with the pawns white
has two pawns and the e and d lines
black only has one it always feels like
black is the one fighting to equalize
and
yeah i think your rank is right often
players especially the top players now
they go back to the oldest openings or
openings which have fallen out of
fashion they discover new things there
and then they start playing it fashions
change everyone copies them then they
look back at what's forgotten again and
that's how fashion changes in chess it's
always at this point there's not much
new under the sun it's always
rediscovering older uh all the
variations like the cambridge uh springs
variation
we did hear magnus in the video in the
break talk about novelties which must be
so nice when you get to play a novelty
so are we seeing a lot of novelties are
we seeing less novelties now
with the with computers and everything
we're still seeing new moves new ideas
novelties but often they're less kind of
groundbreaking than they used to be um
they're
i mean still occasionally but they're
kind of best kind of novelties and
completely brand new uh brand new idea
that nobody's even thought of before and
you use it you win in style you smash
your opponent off the board nowadays
novelties they're kind of new
places to put your pieces small
maneuvering ideas that just confuse your
opponent essentially you don't
i mean it's very rare to win directly
from a novelty nowadays what is that
what is the description of a novelty
what is a novelty if you look it up in
any book it's i guess it's just a brand
new move that's never been played before
um
and the problem doesn't have to be a
good move
ideally
i don't think it should be a bad move
sometimes though it's maybe the third or
fourth choice according to the computer
but it's
kind of got practical value it tests
your opponent from a human point of view
it's harder to react to
um i remember i think my proudest
novelty was against levon aronian in
gibraltar a couple of years ago and
i mean it was just the computer's top
move but nobody had ever found it before
and i played it i i mean i studied it
deeper of course i used it and i won in
20 something moves but um
it's very rare it's like once in a every
few years that you get an idea uh like
that normally because people study with
computers they see the best moves and
they're not surprised and also the the
novelty has it has to happen like my my
former chess coach he has he showed me
this preparation this novelty that he
was gonna play if it ever happened at
that in that exact situation but i don't
know if he still has yeah
he never played any games where so far
at least maybe yeah where he could do
that one move that he's been studying
and he wants to do because it's normally
not like in the like really really early
in the opening it can be a little bit
later aha i once saved up a novelty for
six years i finally finally got a chance
to play it i remembered what the move
was i couldn't remember the follow up
uh i managed to win the game but i think
i spent 55 minutes on one move like just
after the novelty because i was like
what was it
what was it again i remember it was good
but i can't remember what it was and
okay meanwhile a couple of developments
but it's mostly just both kings castling
to safety it's very tense in the center
of the board and
first instincts here heidi now i just
noticed that the players played really
quickly in the beginning and then they
stopped both of them stopped to think
for for um a bit longer so maybe they're
doing like like you they're trying to
remember their way forward in this life
yeah
yeah i feel like this is perhaps a
critical moment actually you know
because uh pragnanda does have the
opportunity to kind of push in the
center or maybe he can kind of continue
with other things so definitely a good
moment to pause i think yeah often
that's a good tip for everyone at home
once you reach the end of your knowledge
once you reach a position that's either
new to you or at least not so familiar
then you should stop um just reassess
calculate a little bit come up with a
plan and you mentioned this move your
anchor pushing forward with the white
pawn has this been played before it has
been played for it's actually not the
most popular move it's just for the one
that
i liked the most because after all
taking a center with the pawns so it's
good in my opinion
and uh they're actually the most popular
move if we take one move back is
actually to trade off bishops
trading bishops first the black queen
will recapture and maybe now to push
forward in the center
yeah actually yes that's an option but
the most popular move again you know
we're talking about margin there's nine
games in database five games white is
actually played in a really
sophisticated way
offering a trade of queens wow okay
interesting so the queen's now staring
at each other if black takes a step back
maybe the black queen's on a worse
square but if black does say yes and
trade the queens then
okay white has some pressure along this
line and maybe white will gain a bit
more space for example actually the
black bishop is lacking squares if the
black pawn pushes forward maybe now you
kick it to the edge of the board and the
black bishop here is not a very happy
bunny also i mean this black knight is
almost trapped as well um it has to take
a step back to some worse squares
so really interesting
in the current position will prague just
try and trade everything off head
towards the end game
and uh trade off the bishops then offer
that trade of queens as we mentioned or
is he going to be more ambitious maybe
keep all the pieces on the board attack
this knight i think i've seen this
position before or at least something's
very similar we'll see a trade of
knights white has a beautiful pawn
center but black does gain a bit of time
black's bishop normally moves to the
edge and when the rook kind of relocates
we do see okay he does go for this we do
see what we call a grunfeld type of pawn
structure because this pawn structure
always comes from the grunfeld opening
usually not this time and at some point
after maybe another trade we'll see
black challenge in the center of the
board either with this pawn or maybe
even with this pawn and white's position
looks nice and pretty at the moment but
black definitely has some ideas
yeah
it's quite interesting because i was
going to say if i had if i just walked
past this board and i didn't know the
evaluation i would prefer to be black in
the in the
uh the position that they were in before
that pawn move just because there are so
many
um
like you can't move the the night and
and the bishop
in the h line is kind of kind of
pointing at
nothing
yeah
but after your uh after you look through
the move then yeah the white looks
better yeah i mean i think you're right
as well i mean black is so active if
black gets one more move and kind of
breaks out in the center and maybe
centralizes some of the black rocks
black is doing well but it's all about
timing and
big moment now for ding if he does trade
the knights as i just showed a moment
ago then white does establish this kind
of perfect pawn center
the problem is what else if you don't
trade these nights you don't really want
to go back
somehow it feels like you're not really
challenging white's center
so much
at some point white might even start
pushing forward gaining a bit of space
and gaining a bit of time as well so
this is the current position it's all
about what to do with this black knight
is under fire and it has to move either
you retreat or you trade off
i'm not sure what doing wants i mean
endgame stats wise
both these players are pretty good at
endgames but
pragnanda ever since he's been young
he's had a special flair
in
kind of simpler positions
and while sting is taking well a
critical moment pause
well we do have a you know quiz of the
day where we're asking what is your
opening nightmare i love listening and
reading out your answers
yeah
i know but i mean the same time it's
like i feel you i feel you i've been
there i've done that and uh christopher
gresley
says speaking of opening disasters
heidi
managed to get this opening trap in as
white in our club championships and uh
it's the famous uh
where you check mate in very few moves
yeah against the carrot card
it was actually quite uh quite uh funny
because i was at the good night the
weekend before i played this game
and we were looking at exactly what
happened here and then it happened just
some days later yeah
really and then you won yeah yeah yeah
and and this game also made it to the
newspaper because it's i think it's
checkmate and it was six moves or
something yeah so um it's very easy to
show in the newspaper column yeah it's
actually caught many unsuspecting
victims
and uh
yeah i know it has and you know remember
simon was talking about uh when he was
playing um an opponent yesterday he was
like nervously shaking it actually
happened
famously in a big danish tournament when
it was a grand master against uh someone
who was rated maybe 600 points below him
and the guy was shaking getting all
nervous like oh you know i'm going to
play my first super grand master and
then he goes and falls for this opening
trap in six moves maybe we can show it
on the board and talk us through it
so you start with the king's pawn uh
ivanka's favorite opening the kara khan
say one of the white knights comes out
we see a trade of pawns in the center
black's night develops just to support
the other night and heidi show us your
brilliant checkmate the white queen
moves
and it's like the most natural move on
the board there it is yeah maybe the
viewers want to see if they can see it
yeah let's check it on one move pause
this uh yeah pause this video just for a
couple of seconds if you want it's white
to play checkmate in one move
well i i was gonna say tweet us your
fantastic hashtag
i need help
just check oh okay okay gotta get the
black king we'll catch up with the game
in a moment you think you're in the
night
yes
nice one and sorry if you've just
tweeted in but uh i think we should show
on the board
yes it's so beautiful the white knight
actually jumps to a square that looks
that it like it can get captured but due
to a pin on this line the black pawn
cannot actually move and uh yeah it's a
bit of a smothered mate the black king
is trapped within and behind its own
pieces so six move track mate wow yeah
in a region we call it a strangling mate
it's like the the king can't breathe
yeah
oh how cool is it is it fun to win like
that or or do you feel a little bit uh
sorry for your opponent never
i am sorry for the brutal honesty
but it's always delightful to win by
checkmate yeah
very cool yeah you've got to be ruthless
in chess
especially when it's quite a pretty
checkmate it's an unexpected one like
that one
and meanwhile back in this game we did
see a trade of knights as we indicated
so white has established a really nice
pawn center
and it's time for black to start
chipping away at white central points
you can't allow white to kind of control
the center this
uh too much longer
if white controls the center maybe then
we'll see a build up of an attack
against the black king maybe the white
pawns in the middle will continue
pushing up the board ding now over the
next few moves it's really critical
moments he needs to push one of his own
black pawns or at least needs to trade
some pieces in order to challenge those
two central white pawns yeah and uh
talking about trades
i would probably just swap those light
square bishops off immediately
because one of the patterns that i'm i'm
kind of terrified of is if the white
pawn in the center that eric the e pawn
were to step one one square forward
and the light squared bishop were to
remain on that diagonal so moved away
from attack
for example uh here yep and suddenly
this bishop is a monster piece you know
it's there is the anchorman or anchor
lady to any light square attack
and uh that is why i'm very relieved for
pr for ding that uh he actually swapped
those bishops off yeah one common
checkmating idea is to lift the queen up
and along this diagonal you kind of
sneak into the black king and uh you
trap it
so uh yup the queen's sorry the bishops
did indeed come off the board um in this
position we saw ding just trade off the
bishops and now he moves his rook across
and i said it was kind of high time to
start pushing one of these two pawns
forward
ding is keeping prague guessing he's
just saying okay i might throw
the black sea pawn forward to trade off
here and open up a line for this black
rook i might throw the e pawn forward
and trade off here to open up a line for
this black rook but
you can guess which one i'm going to
choose depending on what you do
and now ivanka's idea of pushing the
pawn forward still a bit tempting but at
least now there won't be a checkmate
along this diagonal because white has
lost well he's had his light squared
bishop traded off
and uh another piece that wants to join
rejoin the party maybe this bishop um
this bishop hitting thinner it's just
about what to do now is white it looks
it looks really beautiful aesthetically
for white all of his pieces are great
but what to do next one argument could
be maybe pushing this pawn forward
creating a nice kind of trio here but
this would also um just leave a few
squares undefended for example if black
now pushes in the center if you continue
to push with white white hasn't uh sorry
the black knight has a nice outpost now
coming towards the queen
we're going to see a situation at some
point where um in the current position
white does push forward but black will
gain squares and it's just black kind of
curling up into a ball at some point one
of these pawn pushes will occur
it's just it's like mind games in a way
it's kind of ding saying okay you come
at me i'm ready and prag saying i want
to come at you but i'm not sure how
maybe it does involve pushing this pawn
that would just be too tempting for me
but uh either way any pawn pushes
require commitment so advantage sting
then slightly
psychologically maybe but uh i think
objectively on the board i would prefer
to be white just because the pawns look
so nice in the middle
it's just what to do with them yeah
that's the big question yeah i was going
to ask you about um ding's strategy
because you know we can't forget that
pragnanda's so young and one of the
traditional stereotypes is when you're
playing someone who's young
well you know they get a bit over
ambitious they get over-eager impatient
and by adopting this kind of solid as a
rock formation
and waiting for pragnanda to do
something is he kind of tempting him to
making a commitment and then
maybe
play will become easier for ding yeah
quite possibly i mean my kind of go-to
strategy in rapid and
especially blitz chess is actually to do
nothing just make sure everything's
protected curl up in a ball and my
opponents always burn time on the clock
because planning is actually the hardest
thing
i mean the top level players they
calculate so quickly
but when you kind of formulate a plan
that kind of requires four or five moves
you have to consider the opponent's
ideas that's when they really do burn
those valuable seconds and that's what i
mean pregnant is doing now he spent
three minutes on this one move he has
lots of good moves lots of decent moves
lots of interesting plans but just
choosing among the different plans
that's the hardest thing in chess
there are no attacks there are no
variations to calculate really there's
no threats
you just have to choose one plan and
stick with it
uh but yeah he's dropping down a bit on
the clock and i think that's dean's
tactic to answer your question ivanka
he's just happy i think to see prague
thinking
yeah
and the moment the most famous example
i've heard of the do nothing approach
was actually from peter lecko i think
when he played vladimir kramnik right in
their world championship match 2004 yeah
he did i lecco peter lecker did nothing
and like i didn't even i think sometimes
didn't even try to win you know just
there was like a nothing coming from him
and uh this just drove vladimir kramnik
crazy imagine
yeah because it is annoying yeah and uh
peter lecker almost won it
yeah wow he was one game away kramnik
had to win on demand in the last game
just to maintain the title
uh so yeah peter lecker i mean that's
what i love to do just frustrate the
opponent just no matter what it is
whether it's doing nothing whether it's
being super aggressive if you find out
what your opponent hates
that's half the battle um you do it to
them and they get
i don't know they get angry and then uh
yeah
you mentioned like if you find out how
they ha well if you find out what they
hate
how do you do this how do you kind of
like get these signs from their games or
is it perhaps having to not getting to
know the players personally i mean i
i know a lot of the top players but i
try and do this myself i try and
research as much as possible so i play
through hundreds of my opponents games
just to get a
handle on their style if they lose a lot
of games to see
you know what the kind of um
you know what how they lose the game
every single time what those losses have
in common um if they always lose in a
rook end game then i'll try and steal
the game towards a rookie game if they
always lose in a certain pawn structure
i'll try and get that pawn structure if
they're always losing a certain opening
i'll try and trick them into that
opening and i think it's the same for
the top players of course it's small
margins but i think at all levels um
that's so clever this is such a great
piece of advice yeah i've never ever
thought about doing this most of us just
check the openings and say i'll react to
that
but uh i always play through their most
recent 50 100 games and even if it's
quite quick play through you always get
a sense for the patterns that emerge and
i think even at the lower levels you
might not be able to research your
opponent's games maybe the opponent's
games aren't online or on the databases
but you can find out you can talk to
their friends their club mates what are
their weaknesses you know gotta do a
little bit of a spy do a bit of recon
yeah very clever now after thinking for
over four minutes prague eventually did
make a move uh was it the h-pawn move it
was
i mean prague's actually done this in
all games so far today white's pawn just
stepping one square up giving the white
king some breathing space but
that's not the type of move you want to
cost here you want to cost four minutes
and meanwhile ding has slightly improved
black's pawn stepping forward black's
queen now
kind of eyeing up the white rook at the
bottom of the board
it feels like prague is just indecisive
uh what to do next
and uh yeah first instinct it just feels
like he's
he's kind of tensed up he's a bit frozen
he wants to be in a position where the
moves just flow naturally
like in the last game he was calculating
he was improving his pieces on every
turn i'm not sure he's
so comfortable right now i find it so
hard to play when i can't find a plan
when i'm looking for a plan
it's it's the worst yeah that's
definitely the hardest thing in chess
and i think that's one thing that people
forget to train on
just planning just that's why you should
always kind of
read through books read through
magazines especially when the players
talk about their own thoughts just put
the position on the board and see oh how
would i approach this position what do i
think first and then if you can read the
players the top players their own
thoughts
and kind of compare it to your own
conclusions that's
a good way to train and i guess the
saying goes a bad plan is better than no
plan but i heard it's a controversial
thing that is very controversial yeah
it's one where you probably need thai to
do the statistics
where someone had no plan yeah uh yeah
and uh right the bishop actually
retreats all the way to its home square
um presumably just getting ready for any
potential
uh right side attack
yeah he's really mastering the art of
doing nothing ding he's kind of just put
his bishop back on a safe square just
asking prague what are you doing
i have a bad feeling for prague's time
management i mean this is the kind of
thing i do all the time i'm always in
time trouble but if i ask myself
afterwards what was i thinking about
often it was just frustration
um often it was it was like heidi said
just looking for a plan and
kind of beating yourself up it's like i
can't find anything why can't i find
anything and then you kind of stop
calculating
it starts going downhill from there if
you look at the white rooks as well
they're nicely kind of doubled up but
the white rooks are staring at their own
pawn
i don't really see how prague has
improved his position over the last five
moves
and four minutes now it's still quite
early in the game yeah he needs to speed
up right he needs to make a move prague
he looks ready to do it now looking for
that plan
what will the move be the time
management is so difficult as well yeah
is that something you struggle with uh
heidi yeah i i i spent so much time
trying to find the plan try and uh well
i should just swap all the pieces and
then go into the end game because then
it's so much easier for me to find a
plan
talking about plans uh well pregnant has
revealed his intentions and i have to
admit i thought it but again i talked
myself out of this time thing i was like
no
don't go that you don't need to push
pawns in front of your king and
what made me a bit hesitant was that
white doesn't have too many minor pieces
and that light square bishop missing
yeah and i could feel actually you were
going to suggest it a bit earlier
i just had a feeling i nearly showed up
on the board earlier but i thought it's
never going to happen why would we show
it but it has happened and the whole
idea and
we should explain as well black has
something that we call a hook that means
this pawn has moved one square forward
if this pawn was just back on its
starting square then it would be much
harder to attack black structure would
be completely intact but because this
pawn has moved one square forward white
can use it as a hook to kind of wrench
open the position and for example if
black just plays slowly now the white
pawn will push forward trying to open up
lines trying to capture this black pawn
if we see a capture for example the
white knight might start jumping into a
nice attacking position at some point we
might see
again white king slide across white's
rook now uh kind of slide onto this open
line towards the black king stuff is
starting to happen around the black king
the downside and the reason we were so
surprised uh behind this pawn push is
firstly it's a bit slow
the plans that we talked about require
three four moves to push this pawn
forward but also it does open up the
white king as well so it's pros and cons
normally if the centre is closed you can
afford
liberties and luxuries like pushing
pawns near your king but if the center
is open then it will backfire and that's
why ding pushed his pawn forward trying
to open up the center of the board
trying to open up lines for the black
rook and after prague says no i'm going
to close it down again
ding is continuing to push forward and
it's all about timing here
prague might well live to regret the
fact he's pushed this pawn forward and
exposed his king slightly it's a bit
loose now and the white queen no matter
where she goes
i think ding's idea is to bring the
black knight into a lovely outpost
in the middle of the board
the bar is going up for ding 1.1 pawn
advantage is what the computers are
saying and was this simply doing ready
to take advantage of uh prague finally
deciding on a plan yeah i think prague
chose a plan maybe he was thinking oh
bad plans
but
um
yeah i mean it's it's hard to criticize
prague's kind of moves because it's
ambitious i like the idea behind it
going on the attack against the black
king but it's just too slow and look at
how fast ding has mobilized his pawns
it's like a it's like a mirror image of
the first game throwing pawns down
against the white uh queen side i was
gonna call it brutal beth you know it's
gonna be almost a repeat actually if
that pawn is allowed to start marching
even further actually yeah it's
literally a carbon copy of the of the
first game today where ding one just
throwing pawns down where prague wasn't
ready
um
i don't really see what to do now
i mean
no matter what you do with whites it
just feels like black's pieces are
coming to life
wow what a strange date the black
seems to be the pieces to have today
yeah i think that's quite interesting
and i'm wondering if it's because you
know when you play with the white pieces
you're expected to have a little
advantage or you should try to win when
you're playing with the white pieces and
maybe maybe the players are pushing too
much or
not finding the plan properly and it's
actually a good thing to be black yeah
yeah it's easier to kind of just sit and
do nothing and counter-attack as black
and i definitely feel prague we talked
about that pawn push going on the attack
that's because he's white he thinks oh
i've got white i need to win i need to
attack but then sometimes you just you
lose objectivity and uh okay we did see
a quick trade of pawns white's knight
jumping into the center attacking a
black rook but
that look uh that black rook happy to
slide across and support beth the people
and ivanka
i'm loving this um i
it's it feels a little bit cruel though
to pragnanda that it's the same pawn
that's uh that bothered him on game one
is now uh
fully there in pester mode it's ready
game three
um it's really rare that that happens
actually super rare yeah
yeah you very rarely see one player fall
to the same uh defeat twice in a way and
uh the reason we say that this ball is
so dangerous is because you simply can't
take it if you take this pawn right now
then the black bishop comes along and
whoops that's a skewer the white queen
has to move the white rook will drop
behind it on this diagonal so okay
prague is trying to bail out and trying
to escape from this really difficult
situation by offering a queen trade
i'm not sure i'm not sure ding's going
to accept even if he does i think it's
quite good for black but at the very
least you can push your pawn forward two
squares away from promotion now and uh
you can block the queen trade along this
diagonal in the process
you could also make an argument for just
trading queens the very simple approach
and then for example bring the black
knight into this nice outpost maybe now
if you're feeling greedy you could grab
a pawn
i don't think
you can push your pawn forward here i
think the one trap that prague has said
is that if the black pawn does march
forward then after a trade we can see
the white knight eliminate this pawn
beth the b pawn now because after the
white knight is captured whoops loose
pieces drop off and this knight is
hanging and here we would see just
everything getting traded queens knights
pawns and likely a draw so i think
that's what prague's idea is but ding to
trade or not to trade
what do you do here heidi ivanka well i
just
took a look at the computer and the
computer says both of those moves
winning both winning wow and he does
trade and he does grab a pawn so no more
beth the b pawn we have two
charlies what's the seaport charlie
charlie's a good one double charlie and
black is a pawn up temporarily white
goes after one of the weak pawns uh the
double pawns at least and now black
leaping in i'm not such a fan of what
ding has just done i must say um he's
kind of banking on the fact that these
pawns or at least one of them will stay
alive but
if one of them falls maybe the other one
will as well so
okay he's counter-attacking against this
central pawn
okay
developments a capture and another
capture of black is just one pawn up for
free it's one sided traffic yeah
definitely and uh i was just going to
say
that the rook probably was forced to cap
to attack the knight
because
black could even think about attacking
the bishop with the pawn yep at some
point black's pawn can come forward
attack this bishop which is offside on
the edge of the board first now you can
just move your knight any safe square i
think
this one this one
and uh yeah this eventually this one
extra opponent should tell still some
hard work to get it through to start
pushing it
but uh yeah paul is a pawn yeah i've
been really impressed by
ding's handling of the black side of
these openings you know first of all his
first game was a fantastic model game
and this one is also a
great example of just outwitting your
opponent
from something where visually it looks
like it looked quite good for white
and he did nothing and then
he made small improvements here and then
suddenly
he's winning
and some people actually my teammates
tell me this is how i play with kara
khan having like a position which they
look at and they go that's disgusting
and then like and then when they come
back and move 40 they go
i don't know but she's upper porn yeah
and now she's grinding it out um how did
that happen that's exactly ding's
strategy in this game pretty much
uh i know i'm going to go back and study
this opening a bit more because i don't
really know what white went wrong like
where he went wrong what he could have
done instead i mean it's a bit like the
first game prague didn't really blunder
and he was just had a big disadvantage a
few minutes later no
it's hard to explain sometimes it is a
bit
difficult as well and i do know that
this particular opening is very very
trendy and uh it was actually
recommended by sam shankland in his
samislav chesaboard course and there's
actually for those fans of the slav
there's actually a new chessboard course
on the slab semi-slot being released
uh by seth thurman
okay so
more great stuff coming from
everyone at the team at chesmar
absolutely
all right well this one dingley ren
maybe is he heading for another win with
the black pieces and putting prague in
another
uh comeback situation in game four still
one game to play in the first match
today after this game
the night moves yeah the night steps
back i guess the idea is to just go over
and blockade black's extra pawn black's
sea pawn is the dangerous one so maybe
the white knight wants to go and park
itself in front of that pawn but he can
tell him body language suddenly
less optimistic there's no shaking
there's no energy
that we've seen from him
maybe because he's late at night he's
been doing an exam today but
also because of the position on the
board it's one-sided black is the only
one who can win barring a miracle here
white is fighting for his life fighting
for the draw yeah
and okay bishop now attacks the rook and
when you find yourself in these types of
positions do you what do you tell
yourself to motivate yourself
i mean because i know a lot of chess
players they're a bit pessimistic and
they hate being in these horrible
positions and they just go off it's
disgusting why why am i here they do you
do society they question their life
existence even the strong player they're
super strong players are doing this and
they resign and they're just like okay
enough move on to the next
i often have to play even though i know
i'm going to lose i have to play for a
bit longer because i'm so upset
inside that i have to like calm down
before before i give up but i also think
uh because i mean my level is obviously
a lot lower than these guys that you can
learn a lot even though you play a bad
position maybe you can you can learn how
to
try to defend as good as possible and so
i often also continue playing just to
play more chess even though it looks
horrible
yeah that's actually good that's really
good advice actually to kind of adapt to
the learning mentality
yeah and i i mean ever since i read this
book by jonathan rouse and the seven
deadly chess sins i call it the
goalkeeper's glory it's um basically a
goalkeeper in football soccer
i mean you don't you never score goals
you never actually win anything
especially for example in a penalty
shootout nobody expects you to save it
but if you do like in a chess game in a
hopeless position if you do save it you
feel on top of the world you're the hero
you're not going to win the game
necessarily but a draw feels like a
victory so i just kind of think of
myself in a losing position like a
goalie i'm like okay
not much chance but i'll try and save it
if i can i'll try and stop my opponent
from scoring oh i can imagine you david
burning gold
if i can do it
and i especially think in like if you're
a beginner you have to play and no
matter what if you're playing against
other beginners because i've seen so
many games that look like they were 100
one
for for one side and then the other one
wins yeah
you always learn something along the way
anyway in terms of defense or how to
finish things off
uh meanwhile prague he didn't look happy
there a minute ago just rubbing his eyes
but he has at least blockaded black's
extra pawn black sea pawn for now can't
move
problem is this white knight's not on a
stable square this white knight can get
kicked away by black's rook or by
black's bishop
i would be very tempted to move the
black bishop now to hit this knight oh
he does not look happy pregnant on the
other bar
all the way up for dingley ran is he
going to win another game here
it's certainly looking good for ding
and
well the move that david recommend is on
the boards and well prank is in full
goalkeeper mode you know knight was
attacked i had to be defended
yeah and uh here question for ding how
to progress how to kind of you've got
the one point advantage how to keep that
momentum going how to really kind of try
and kick pregnant while he's down
especially while he's got one minute on
the clock and a couple of options here i
mean first thing that comes to my mind
is just keep things simple get rid of
the blockade of your porn knights of the
best blockaders so eliminate it and why
not just get greedy grab this pawn two
pawns up
it still takes a lot to win this
actually these pawns they don't run that
quickly
surprisingly they will be stopped by the
white rooks but two-point advantage no
risk at all
should be winning i think long term
another idea would be to maybe sideline
this bishop first i'm slightly concerned
about this bishop taking the black
knight and wrecking the black pawn
structure it's a fair trade but maybe
you don't want to compromise your pawn
structure you could push this pawn
forward
okay he doesn't want to allow that
bishop for nitrate uh instead of pushing
a pawn he goes back with the black
knight hitting this rook and maybe
there's a root for this knight into the
position for example if it moves uh if
the white rook moves maybe the black
knight is jumping in this way towards
the white rook interesting uh
interesting idea there from ding i mean
he's got a pawn he's got an extra pawn
he's hit making threats
he's the one in control three extra
minutes on the clock as well it's just
hard
it's hard to imagine saving this in any
world at the moment
less than 30 seconds now for prague
okay and uh he retreats his rook one
square i like this one at least it
stopped the black knight going to the
other square i mentioned because the
white rook was attacking black's sea
pawn so black's knight now on the
defensive
oh what's that white bishop doing you
mentioned it heidi like what was it 20
moves ago that white bishop it's just
been sidelined actually on the side of
the board
pushing forward
that pawn's going nowhere but at least
it's not targeted by the black rook
look at prague
it seems like he's just finished with
this game planning the next one
or does he look tired i don't know i
think he looks tired i think it was this
exam yeah to get up
at it was his exam was at 8 45 yeah so
he finished the final at the semi-final
yesterday at 2 30 in the morning in
india and then he had to be at school by
8 30 to do his exam
and then turning up here at uh was it 9
30 in india i think it's what is it past
midnight now
it's not easy
um yeah i mean he's a superhuman effort
to even get this far to win the last
game but this one is falling apart dingo
still has to win it he still has to put
that ball in the back of the net
how to do that i mean the black rook now
uh on the second low on the second line
on b2 could just take a step back kick
away this white knight
as soon as that black pawn starts
motoring it should be
came over
hmm
it's a little bit of a position where
the pieces are all over the board it's
not like they're centralized somewhere
where is sort of the main area for ding
to get that win i think it's all about
that black sea pawn actually if you look
at if you forget the white pieces for a
moment if you only look at black's army
they've all gravitated to the b and the
c files so that's where black's kind of
focuses he doesn't need to worry about
the black king queens are off there
won't be any attacks so black's focus is
now on the b and c files but especially
the black seaborne that is the potential
winner that's his extra pawn white's
army uh you mentioned that kai white is
the one that's actually a bit scattered
there's less coordination and harmony
especially that white bishop on the edge
of the board white's rook in the center
looks nice and pretty but not really
doing much and there we go
the blockader is getting kicked away and
the white knight now on the edge
eyeing up the black bishop but the black
bishop can just move maybe you don't
even need to move it yeah i thought she
can also be supported as well by a porn
so
the choice is in ding's hands yeah i'm
starting to understand why pregnant has
given up hope it just looks
i mean completely lost unfortunately
the black bishop attacking white's rook
the white rook will step up one square
yeah maybe the black pawn is coming now
maybe the black bishop can move okay
there we go the pawn does advance
white's rook in front of it is
completely
cut out of the game white's rook now and
the white knight in the corner
just immobilized
well 30 seconds for prague he's going to
keep fighting right it's not like he's
going to give up right now i think until
that black pawn continues to break
through or until something else drops
yeah you're only one point down for now
so keep fighting the computer does save
plus five nearly yeah so that means that
it's almost hopeless but
in human times
nine seconds for brag it's not much time
it's always very uh
nerve-wracking yeah the players let the
seconds tick down
okay so the rook moves across you know
potentially setting up a trap as the two
rooks eye each other out there's
unfortunately i think this might be the
killer blacks rook is just removing the
blockader of his seaporn white's rook
now on the c2 square stuck if you trade
off rooks black is just going to create
beth the b pawn again and going to queen
that pawn again
and uh there we go we have a result ding
takes it wow it's over again with the
black pieces